Tessa Dunlop you've been seething away
quietly to my left I can see you
simmering to simmer
away you are pull me peers occasionally
I think no he's found the light he's
seen the light he's no longer crashing
on about Harry and then this appalling
di tribe we've just had to sit through
you claiming you lying there suggesting
that you're putting their names out
effectively to save the monchy you put
their names out for clicks you no better
than omed scobby in fact you're worse
you call him a lick spittle you're a
great big gar of fleem that's just
landed on the Royal dorat I don't know
how you slept last night I struggled to
sleep thinking about what You' done I
really can't and yes I did I didn't know
that stop stop the performative crap
honestly it's performative crap no let's
just hold on to calm down have civilized
conversation idea you didn't sleep over
this you don't even know these people I
was no I was properly angry by your
hypocrisy and then
you because you spend day in day out
your pro monarchy the wonderful Queen
wonderful Charles and then you go and do
Kate and Charles right in it when one's
at 28 yes you did wait a
minute oh yes you I'll tell you who did
that omed scobby because these names
appeared in a draft of his book which
was published in the Netherlands they
were under the line to NE was title
tattle to you popped it on a Murdock
platform and now you've just had the
goal to suggest you're right now I know
I am correcting the record the record
that was Pi's highly dubious opinion
I've got a problem with you tonight
peers a real problem why would you have
a problem with a being on a murd up
platform because what you did was you
put those names you're being paid to
appear yes I know but you took the name
the rumor the rum and you put it on an
official platform why you being you
turned it from fiction why you accepted
money from a Mur to challenge you about
your behavior and theocracy and by the
way just the word Basel how do you know
that Megan's rumors were baseless how do
you know what she accused of but where's
the evidence was baseless where well
obviously it's very difficult when the
two are the chief witness they couldn't
even decide on Oprah Winfrey what year
these supposed conversations had
happened or how many there were right
they couldn't decide what year doesn't
mean it didn't happen really take notes
and write in your diary happen let me go
to Dicky I I just want to come in you
you mentioned the Oprah interview and
quite frankly Megan said that it
happened the conversation happened when
she was pregnant about 10 minutes later
Harry came into the interview and said
it happened before they were married so
when did it happen and did it happen and
there's a big question mark I will take
issue with you naming yesterday and I
made that point this morning um you are
a bit of a law onto yourself worse than
a la excuse me I didn't interrup
actually just on the law point it was
entirely lawful what I did so I did seek
legal advice I got very good sound Le
and actually there's no question I
didn't take the law onto myself I
actually applied a letter of the law
this information had been published in
the Netherlands Dutch people were free
to read it and I took a view it was
ridiculous the British people couldn't
be aware of this information I also said
when I named them that I didn't believe
a word of the racist allegations made
against them I didn't either I didn't
either didn't believe anything of that
that that interview it was just a dire
tribe of absolute nonsense as is the
book endgame and as you rightly say end
game the only person endgame is is
scobby but I did take isue in in
mentioning him last night yes you have
say the Brits have a right to know uh
it's in the Dutch uh translation
but there are those who will say agree
with you there were those who disagree
with you well many of the papers who've
held off apparently tonight are going to
name you gave them no choice you always
got a choice sorry you always have a
choice everybody's got a choice everyone
has a choice everyone had a choice when
it was published in the Netherlands not
to repeat the names right if they're all
going to repeat them tonight in the
papers they were just a day after us
right and I have a show called
unsensitive a reason I don't believe in
self-censorship I don't believe when the
Dutch people can read this information
in a book available in bookstores as
some of them had already bought copies
that British people should be denied
that information and the information by
the way is hugely significant we've
waited two and a half years to find out
who these members of the royal family
were that Mega Mar weird people like
session PE waiting no no actually the
entire country has no misrepresentation
of most of the country what I actually
want to know is he said he had no help
from thees and yet on the other hand you
said he saw the letters yeah so how did
he see the letters how how has he got
the information exactly he's not got it
from King Charles it's all come from
monito right Paula thank you wow okay so
you're going to be shocked at this but I
actually agree with you that you named
that you identified them yesterday and
let me explain to you why because
everybody in the Royal Circle knew who
it was all the Royal journalists knew
who it was I've spoken to people who
knew who it was the fact that they've
been named didn't come as a surprise to
me because it's fairly common knowledge
among journalists I actually don't think
many journalists knew about Princess of
Wales I think they thought it was
another member of the royal family but
you
accept well I was actually surprised but
I was not surprised that again it made
it even more to me obvious that this is
all complete bull crap exactly and
that's where you and I actually agree on
this because the the the fact that it
was they they were named in the
Netherlands is almost neither here nor
there the fact is there are people here
who knew and you're right the British
people did have a right to know who it
was and now we know who it is what's
going to happen next well surely action
needs to be taken and here's where I am
disappointed with you I'm disappointed
with you because we had a monologue of
you berating and throwing disdain at uh
at Megan at Harry at Omid talking as if
you have spoken to King Charles talking
as if you have spoken um to Kate spoken
as if you have spoken to Camila but you
haven't and so if you haven't everything
that you have said is based on
assumption and I think you did accept
and I think you did accept actually and
and everyone no no because you actually
used the word assumptions in what you
were saying you are also making very D
you are also making very dangerous
assumptions and what you have done this
evening is you have set anybody back who
is suffering from
racism forward because you are
suggesting you are suggesting that
because of what
somebody and because of their role in
society that you cannot challenge them
that is what you have said this evening
and that is dangerous it doesn't matter
who put back RAC it doesn't matter who
it is tell who's put back racism people
who cry wolf about racism I don't know
if they're cry they're despicable CRI
I've been assured assured who by who
never you mind oh come on you're not
going to your sources and I've been
assured but you name the allegations let
name your SCE who your SCE I don't
reveal any sources right but I've been
assured on what you're saying
importantly where is the evidence in the
letters no doubt where in the letters no
doubt I would whats I would like to see
these letters cuz no that's where the
evidence you ask where the evidence is I
suggest now we may have started
something where we I want to waake I
don't want to wait a thousand years I
don't want them to be locked away in
some cell somewhere I think you're going
to ACC members of the royal family of
racism you should have the decency and
the courage to stand up say who it was
say what theym and you about decy say
when they said it I I I'm flabbergasted
so you're the victim of racism but
you're challenging the victim on having
decency on being decent is that what
you're saying who the victim because I
know incredibly the vitim incredibly
difficult don't know but I do know
you're talking about mythical victim I
do know is ridiculous conversation Harry
and Megan so I'm apparently I'm
apparently disrespecting some victim but
you don't know who that is you're you're
challenging what they're saying it's not
true you're Challen how do you know
where's the proof well two and a half
years so so what we're waiting for is
evidence and then once you've got the
evidence and then once you've got your
evidence will you apologize racist
you got your evidence will you apologize
yeah you apologize to don't get me wrong
will apologize to me mega marle produces
actual evidence of racism let's see it
and if if it's proven that King Charles
the Princess of Wales were racist about
her a baby I will apologize to her let
me tell you I can say that with real
confidence because it ain't G to happen
because you haven't apologized yet for
the fact that you were wrong about the
threats that were made of on her life
terms of all the fire right groups on
the terms of who I didn't talk about
that they she said that they affected
her mental health and you said that she
was lying no no I didn't it it again
you're Mis you're misquoting me I didn't
say that I said I didn't believe she
went to a senior member of the royal
household and said she was she was
feeling suicidal and they wouldn't allow
her to get help and no evidence for that
has ever been produced and nor has that
allegation ever reappeared in the
Netflix series The Harry book or the
podcast it didn't happen you accept
happen they would have been repeated you
AC that she suffered from her mental
health do you she idea wasn't there was
I all I know is she did not go to a
senior member of the royal household
saying I'm suicidal and they said you
can't get help you've just said you
don't know about her mental health and
yet you said with assurity earlier in
this conversation that her claims about
racism about the questions of the color
of her baby they were baseless how can
you say that with a shorty when you
weren't there the pro you weren't
there's the proof unless she was sitting
there with a tap
let's take a short break come let's talk
a short break and we'll come back I mean
hysteria is fine to a point it's a bit
performative
youy try and stay on point no no no I
made my point you can have an argument
without being hysterical it's a bit
pathetic